so how many have you actually seen this
email at some point in time now now the
thing is that in this email who
remembers what did they ask you to do if
you actually come across a mountain lion
absolutely now we won't judge you if you
say that strategic communication is
probably the last thing on your mind if
you actually come across a situation
like this it's very obvious but yet if
you actually closely look at the
contents of the email it actually asks
you to probably take certain actions
which I actually taught in this class
now as human beings we don't comprehend
that we'll ever come across a situation
like this but our ancestors thousands of
years back but actually this would be
quite common for them on an everyday
basis and the actions they will take how
quickly they will move the body language
that they will portray or the sounds
they'll make could make a difference
between a hearty meal and being eaten
hotly over a period time with evolution
humans created language and with
language we started getting more and
more dependent on words and something
that Martin actually already spoke about
that 95 percent of what people treated
people comes from how they feel but yet
we have concentrated probably more than
95% on the words that we use social
scientists have actually proven that
close to 55 percent of the impact that
you can make on people comes from your
body and the posture that you make in
front of people how many times have you
actually had this instance where you're
presenting at a meeting where people are
supposed to be really interested in what
you're gonna say and they are probably
sitting like this and that's why social
scientists believe that humans are
probably the worst species today in the
world to actually learn body language
from because we all give conflicting
signals and they can recommend that you
go back to the basics and actually study
animals
to understand the real power of body
language so unsurprisingly we can draw
parallels to the lessons we've learned
in this course about nonverbal
communication with animal behavior and
typically and typically typically when
we think about nonverbal communication
we think about submissive or dominant
behavior when it comes to animals
however two the key lessons that we
learned and energy communication focused
on appearing appearing appearing
appearing focus
appearing larger versus appearing
smaller and ensuring eye contact with
the audience now for example when we are
appearing smaller we tend to turn
inwards we hunch down we cross our arms
we close our legs and sometimes we even
run and behind objects out of fear from
the audience
similarly in the animal kingdom when we
appear when animals are appearing
smaller they tend to have submissive
behaviors they also hi they also appear
small and they also appear small
and all these nominee
essentially the submissive animal is
giving up his or her power to the
dominant animal contrasting that when we
appear larger we make our bodies take up
as much space as possible we own our
territory
we walk around we stand with our hip
with our feet hip width apart and we
open our arms
it's confident unafraid of the audience
similarly in the animal kingdom primates
or alpha male primates they typically
open up as well they also open up their
arms they also tend to position
themselves aggressively ready to fight
well we certainly don't want to mimic
what animals do because we probably
wouldn't have any friends professor Amy
Cuddy talks about power poses and power
poses mimic the type of poses that we
want to have open postures being able to
take up territory in space and these are
dominant dominant dominant power poses
however when we have low power poses we
tend to be inwards as well and as you
can see these replicate submissive body
language the last lesson that we
actually learned was also ensuring eye
contact with the audience and the reason
why we need to ensure our eye contacts
because we want to make a connection
with the audience members now sometimes
if we don't make that connection the
audience thinks that we're fearful but
when we do make that connection they
believe that we're confident and strong
similarly in the eye and the animal
kingdom not making eye contact with
another can be a submissive sign and so
however one of the ways you can dominate
someone with eye contact in the animal
kingdom is if you hold a stare long and
I don't know about you but if you had
ever had an experience with someone is
staring at you for a long period of time
you tend to move back and that's our
primitive number of
q that is phantom4 but let's take it one
step further how many of you by show
hands think I am an introvert
it's irrelevant okay the point the point
was that by the time I reached the
center of the stage you almost of you
already formed an opinion of me research
shows that it takes as little as one
tenth of a second 1/10 of a second for
us to judge someone just based on face
body posture am i confident
am i strong am i trustworthy am i a liar
am i a leader or my follower how is that
possible how can we frame somebody in a
split second just based on visuals again
it's animal communications and basic
instinct since the beginning of time
we've been trained like animals to
identify creatures as predators or prey
as leaders of followers and we had to do
that in a split second because it's a
matter of life and death often so we
like animals communicate way before we
even speak and we'll do that in a blink
of an eye
why does that matter well effective
communication is a matter of survival
powerful performances can lead people to
act as much as they can stop a mountain
lion from attacking weak ones can turn
people against you or can turn you into
a meal for liable so it is critical to
learn for all of us to learn effective
communication skills to be able to make
good first impressions and carry them
forward in social situations or in
public speaking engagements and we
believe animals can teach us a lot about
it and I want to show you one little
example this screencast is a hero he's
facing is facing a big audience a big
mouth much greater than now and in Syria
look at the communication skills strong
stance excellent eye contact he's making
himself big as big as it can get and he
moves with purpose towards the audience
but not too close he's gonna survive
probably by faking it I'm sure is
terrorized inside and Alicia poorhouse
so whenever we meet somebody that we're
scared of an employer an investor or a
mountain lion a hiking trail remember we
remember the little hero
stand big and tall maintain eye contact
move with purpose and stay calm and
breathe it will serve you well now we
open up for questions
yeah especially if you're having a group
meeting or group session where you know
the individuals you tend to want that
more or less at have a friendly
conversation or friendly vibe so in that
situation you don't want to have a big
posture you kind of wanted more or less
like follow the group in order to create
like that camaraderie in general
maintaining eye contact just like when
you deal with the with a person you
don't want to stare at somebody too
close too intensely because that that is
freaky same same with animals you want
to maintain eye contact and in some
animals maybe may have more power than
others and then in that case and what it
may want to be more intense but you know
if you read books they say maintain eye
contact but sometimes you know move your
move your eyes away just not to be too
threatening and one of the key signals
that you can see from a person if you
feel that the stare maybe the gaze maybe
too long is that they start walking back
away from you and that's a key signal
that you're probably having a your eye
contacts a little bit too strong for
them that dates nothing yeah yes Jamie
I don't think there's any tension calm
and breathing or not and and being tall
and big are not mutually exclusive I can
be tall and big and just be completely
calm and and and breathe it in so there
are two different states two different
things but animals can sense when you're
not calm and that's they actually want
you to become tense and because that
made makes makes you weaker same with
you know public speaking engagements of
them the moment you become tense and
nervous that's when you basically like
me yesterday you had a question how come
so this was exactly we were sitting in
the bath library and we were discussing
what topic we should be going by and
that's when these email message actually
picked up and that's fair coincidently I
just clicked on the link which actually
says that if you want more details and
it just came to us that probably this is
would be an interesting topic to just
look at yeah and power posing is one of
those topics on professor Amy Cuddy
she's had a TEDx talk about it and she
gives us advice that holding those power
poses are being able to like you know be
in a power position for two minutes even
before an interview can be very helpful
and can like lose your confidence for
that event
so now that we have covered the bar
doing all these sport together and we
actually got a question as well that how
do you maintain that we're going to show
you an experiment which was done by some
BBC correspondent where they pitted
against 15 starving lions the most
powerful weapon that a man has and
that's his confidence and his body
posture and we're gonna share the video
with you actually what the results was
don't worry it's not gory so as it
happens these lines have just killed a
parade after almost four days and there
as a family now feeding on their kill
and the three people out there one of
them is a very experienced hunter but
they are not carrying any weapons with
them except some bow and arrow which is
not gonna help of course a 15 lines
attack you all together and just see
what the group
so in the in the in the axle the sound
you will actually hear this gentleman
talking about all you have with you is
your confidence and your body posture
against these lines and the lines
actually run away and they go on to
actually take a piece of the kill that
the lines had just killed upon and take
it with them without getting harmed by
the lines so this is a picture you
wanted to share with you so that the
next time you put it against either an
audience of hundred or the ten top-notch
VCS who are known to be really really
anal please go back to this video and
just remember what counts is your own
ability to stand in front of people and
with confidence thank you